Another Thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No, Dr. Bright, you
can't have a pet SCP!
We don't care how many O5 Council members
agree to it, or if there have been precedents
set by previous cases.
Dr. Bright has not proven himself responsible
enough to have a pet SCP of any kind.
We gave him a goldfish, and he promised to
keep it alive for a year.
He failed.
We gave him a potted plant, and he promised
to take care of that.
It lasted a week.
Giving Dr. Bright a dangerous anomaly to care
for would be a huge security risk, and giving
him a harmless SCP would certainly constitute
animal cruelty.
And no, he absolutely cannot have SCP-999.